Welcome back everyone this will be my brand
new marvel daredevil video they just announced
officially that they are making their brand
new daredevil tv series for disney plus so
i'll explain what's going on what the timeline
is all the connections and where we're gonna
see daredevil show up next because he will show
up before the new daredevil episodes as well as
kingpin he's coming back before that as well
as some of the other characters too probably
how did you just do that i'm a really good lawyer
if you're brand new to the channel of course i'll
be doing videos for the new daredevil series
when it premieres it's gonna be a little while
but we do have obi-wan kenobi episodes happening
next week i'll be doing full episodes for that be
sure to subscribe to get everything and i will do
a disney plus giveaway in all those episode videos
but we just saw daredevil come back during spider
man no way home a really good lawyer is now back
officially in the mcu if you didn't think he
was in the mcu before i think we all thought
that they would bring him back eventually charlie
cox had been talking about it for years and years
and years since they had cancelled the netflix
marvel series one of the reasons why it took
so long to hear about this is marvel just came
control of all the episodes all the characters
from netflix so that's why they brought them all
to disney plus so that should have been the key
that they're bringing a lot of these characters
back the whole idea with daredevil in the mcu now
as of spider man no way home as well as kingpin
because of what happened during the hawkeye series
is they're treating the events of the daredevil
series as if they're loosely canon to the mcu
so what that means is when they do these new
daredevil episodes it's not going to be like
a complete reboot of everything pretty much all
the same main characters will come back they'll
probably be like a few minor characters that they
might recast but all the big characters that you
would expect them to bring back and they'll
just play it as if daredevil has been a lawyer
operating inside the mcu inside this version of
new york city all these years and the events of
the daredevil series already happen so the plot
of these new daredevil episodes when it premieres
will be set forward in the timeline in whatever
the present day is when that series picks up
we learned a little bit more about what's actually
happening in the timeline of daredevil from the
kingpin scenes during the hawkeye series
because vincent d'onofrio talked a lot
about what he was doing with the character when
he came back and how close he was to the original
version the way he talked about it is that he
played it as if it was the original version
but they're kind of re-skinning the character
just to make him look a little bit different
and they're not treating every single thing as if
it's 100 candidates the events of the daredevil
netflix series are like 98 percent canon this is
kevin feige and vince d'onofrio talking about that
talk about organized crime in the marvel universe
and you talk about the cd underbelly of new york
city there is one primary character that comes to
mind he said i want to bring you into the mcu and
i'm not going to say no to that like that's pretty
awesome i really loved playing this character i
liked creating him you know from the art of guys
like david mack fisk is really driven by emotion
you know he's like a child and a monster both at
the same time so it got very intense yesterday and
got a little bit intense today too so what they're
talking about is that they don't want to mess with
what they've already set up with the character
like they're not going to completely change
everything but like they actually just sold off
all the props including the daredevil costume
from the original series so like they don't even
have the original costume anymore there's been a
lot of talk about them giving him a brand new
daredevil costume that looks a little bit more
comic book accurate when he debuts in the actual
costume in a new episode on a disney plus series
i just did a video for the she-hulk trailer that's
supposed to be the next place where we'll see matt
murdock's daredevil character i don't know about
the other characters there's been talk of jessica
jones showing up from the netflix series and
kristen ritter coming back but a lot of the
scenes in the she-hulk trailer take place in los
angeles like this is the los angeles city scape
and matt murdock is mostly local to hell's kitchen
like that's why a lot of the hawkeye series took
place in hell's kitchen because you saw kingpin's
character even though he's active around all of
new york city and he lives around midtown a
lot of the series took place in midtown too
most of the really shady stuff that he does is
localized to around hell's kitchen like that's the
reason why you saw so much hell's kitchen during
hawkeye that's also why they timed the release of
them bringing kingpin back to the release of
them bringing daredevil back in the mcu like
big surprise both of these daredevil characters
coming back around the exact same day almost i've
done a couple videos about them bringing him back
because i think we all believed that they were
bringing him back and a lot of websites had been
reporting this supposed daredevil timeline in the
mcu leading up to his brand new solo series so it
all started with spider man no way home a really
good lawyer matt murdock shows up in the mcu he's
been here this whole time like as if the series
took place in the mcu so they would have also
gone through a version of the snap in the blip
then they bring kingpin back on the hawkeye series
so okay that means that most of these characters
exist in the mcu in some form the building in
hawkeye episode 1 is the building that kingpin
bought in the daredevil finale during season three
then they set up the relationship between kingpin
and echo which is a big comic book relation she
winds up blinding him with that gun and then he
sort of goes to ground but eventually comes back
with a very temporary blindness big daredevil
easter egg being blind but those characters are
supposed to come back in a bigger way during
the echo series just yesterday because of all
the tv upfronts marvel announced all the plans
they have for the upcoming tv series like that's
why we got the she-hulk trailer during that they
also released the very first preview of a scene
from the echo series featuring her character so
obviously it's going to deal mostly with her
backstory and what's going to be happening
with her in the mcu but daredevil kingpin and a
couple of the other core daredevil characters are
supposed to be part of that series in a much
bigger way than they were during the hawkeye
series or during spider man no way home but
because they're just ramping up on that series and
they're getting ready to debut she-hulk episodes
technically she-hulk is supposed to be the next
place where we'll see charlie cox's daredevil
character and during that supposedly we're going
to see him in a brand new mcu daredevil costume
of some sort they're both lawyers for people with
superpowers both superheroes and supervillains
like you see a version of the cube which is like
another big marvel prison where they're keeping
abomination during the trailer even though a lot
of it does seem like it takes place during los
angeles jennifer walters is going to be running
this superhuman defense team for her law firm
it would make sense that she would run into matt
murdock as a lawyer through the court system but
they could also run into each other as vigilantes
at night i don't know if kingpin are the other
daredevil characters are going to be featured
during that like i said there could be a jessica
jones type of cameo scene during that as well
there's been rumors so we get those episodes then
we get the echo episodes with daredevil then after
the echo episodes debut that's when the daredevil
solo series is supposed to debut so right now
because they just announced they hired the writer
they have to actually write the episodes and then
they'll cast it then they'll start shooting it
the earliest we'd be able to see episodes would be
like the very end of next year or like early 2024
so it's gonna be a little while but like i said
we will see more daredevil in the mcu in these
other disney plus series before that and even
though he was trying to be very misleading and not
give away spoilers about being back in spider-man
no way home he said a lot of things that have
supported this like yes i would always love
to come back i would love to bring those other
daredevil characters back and now it's all coming
true and you know it'd be really fun the one thing
that being in the mcu allows that we couldn't
really do in the with the netflix stuff is that
i can now interact with other mcu characters um
so i'd like that would be really cool
crossovers would be really is the
thing i would like to do next i don't know
what that looks like and i don't know what
you know what they're planning and all that kind
of stuff but you know that that's there are some
really interesting stories there that i would like
to i'd love for the character to explore after all
those spider-man no way home scenes now people
just want to see daredevil spider-man daredevil
interacting with other characters one of the big
things that he said that he's really excited for
is that now daredevil can actually have those
big comic book interactions that you saw
with these other huge marvel characters that they
could not do when he was on netflix even though
his scenes during spider-man no way home were
amazing they were very brief they did shoot a lot
more footage that hit the cutting room floor there
were a lot of deleted scenes with matt murdock and
jon favreau's happy hogan character joking about
him previously being a version of foggy nelson in
that ben affleck daredevil movie though a lot of
people wondering if they'd ever do a ben affleck
daredevil cameo depends on whether or not he
would want to come back to do that it would
have been funny to see him walk by during doctor
strange too but if most of you don't remember
john favreau even though he's mostly known for
directing things especially the mandalorian
series and all the star wars stuff now he's also
been an actor for a long time he played a version
of foggy nelson during that ben affleck daredevil
movie there were a ton of kingpin deleted scenes
on the hawkeye series that's kind of been true of
all the marvel disney plus series like there was
going to be a black knight cameo scene during the
moon knight series so like everything cool that
you've wanted them to do with any of these disney
plus ears they probably thought about doing it or
did it and then went up deleting it at the end of
the day i've done a bunch of separate videos about
all those deleted scenes so i'll link them in the
description below if you want to see some of them
there's enough kingpin mcu deleted scenes to
almost do an entire separate series for hawkeye
for those of you asking if they're bringing back
the other marvel netflix defenders characters like
you obviously have iron fist you have jessica
jones you have blue cage you have the punisher
character right now the way that kevin feige has
talked about it it's sort of like a wait and see
kind of thing like whoever's most appropriate for
any given series he'll reach out to them like he's
always game to bring people back even though i'm
not really hot on the idea of them bringing back
the netflix version of iron fist i'm hoping they
kind of recast that or reimagine it somehow in the
mcu a really notable iron fist story that happened
when they were released in the shi movie is that
jessica henwick who originally played a version of
colleen wing during that series said that she was
supposed to come back as a different character
in the shangshi movie i think she was supposed
to play sheng shi's sister in one of the reasons
why she chose not to come back in the shangshi
movie why she declined it because the money was
about the same for both of the different movies
is that if she starred in the shangshi movie
it would sort of preclude her coming back as
a version of colleen wing and she didn't
want to close the door on her version of
colleen wing coming back so yes punisher could
come back eventually if they figure out where
would be the best place to put him but right now
the only marvel netflix defender character who has
said that they have not been contacted by marvel
and just seemed way too busy to actually come back
would be mike coulter's luke cage character but
it's not because he doesn't want to come back so
that's why kevin feige doesn't completely recast
all those characters right away because some of
them could potentially come back in the future
so we're just kind of leaving that door open
but if you have any questions about what's going
on with these brand new daredevil episodes just
post them in the comments below i'll do more
daredevil easter eggs as they show up during
the she-hulk episodes some of you also been
asking me about doing merch for my channel
or how to support the channel now youtube is
actually letting you support me by leaving tips
on my videos using that special heart underneath
each of the actual videos it's right here they're
supposed to give you guys some special power-ups
whenever you do that for each of my videos so when
you try that out let me know if it's working for
you so if you want to support the channel that's
the best way to do it right now thank you to all
of you for all of your support everyone click here
for my full she-hulk trailer video in easter eggs
and click here for my brand new deadpool 3 teaser
breakdown in easter eggs thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and maximum effort!